this video is brought to you by
brilliant problem-solving based website
and app with a hands-on approach
it's January to make a resolution to
improve your STEM skills this year a
brilliant at org /by graphics more on
them in a bit when it comes to a
person's goals dreams and life's work it
seems like there would be few pursuits
more worthy than alleviating world
hunger
surely bringing food to the starving
masses bringing crops to barren areas of
the world and averting famine death and
disease is a lofty ambition isn't it
Norman Borlaug truly believed so and he
made it his life's work to create crops
that would relieve food shortages across
the globe even though his name is hardly
a household one there's no denying that
he shaped the world's food supply in
such a way that it's still being felt
today for better or for worse Borlaug
was born in 1914 he lived through World
War 1 started college during the Great
Depression saw the American Midwest turn
into the Dust Bowl and it was then that
he decided he was going to spend the
rest of his life
introducing high yield crops to areas
who could benefit from them and that has
turns out to be surprisingly
controversial murmurs of discontent and
criticism started in the 1980s and over
the following decades Borlaug's methods
would come under an ever increasing
amount of scrutiny he remains resolute
though man's the world well whether it
benefitted from his work or was
infinitely hurt by it is still up the
debate
[Music]
while some people finds their life
calling late in life others have their
life's work shaped by their earliest
memories that was certainly the case
with norman borlaug born on March the
25th 1914 he grew up on a small farm in
Iowa those childhood years were shaped
by hard work and subsistence farming
that is farming that yields just enough
for the survival of the family with
little or nothing left over for sale or
profit it was an incredibly hard life
made even harder by the fact that this
was an era before there was help from
mechanization and tractors for much of
his youth in fact that wasn't even
electricity when he enrolled in school
in 1919 it really was a mile and a half
each way even though that sounds like a
bit of a cliche he thrived in school and
he thrived on the farm where he spent
his hours doing the chores that had been
tasked with since he could walk
collecting eggs pulling weeds and
feeding the chickens the trolls of
course got more difficult as he got
older and working on a farm like this
there was no one job that he was in
charge of he did everything from caring
for the animals to separating cream from
the milk mens when times were
particularly harsh and during outbreaks
of influenza that would kill several
family friends he would carry hot soup
to neighbors who had been quarantined in
their homes living through that sort of
hardship undoubtedly gives a young boy a
complete appreciation for struggles in
Borlaug's case he would become
determined to alleviate them for others
with little time for extracurricular
activities it may have seems like a
young Borlaug would grow up to take over
the family farm and follow in his
father's footsteps but one person
changed those plans his 7th grade
teacher who was also his cousin
recommended he be sent to high school
and he was Cresco high school was 12
miles from the family farm and of course
there were no buses Borlaug eventually
moved to town started participating in
school sports like wrestling and
football and found himself given one of
the greatest gifts a child can receive a
teacher who inspired him his name was
Harry Schroeder and he was the
vocational agriculture teacher Borlaug
had been raised with the belief
particular to the area and culture he
had been immersed in as a farmer with a
close connection to the land he had held
sacred the richness and fertility of the
aya
soils and their ability to grow the
crops that would nurture and sustain the
people who lived that but when his
teacher had the students set up a
year-long experiments where they grew
crops in both unfertilized soil and soil
augmented with things like potassium
nitrogen and phosphorus the results
proved a valuable lesson the Augmented
soil yielded almost twice the amount of
food and that ended up being a
life-changing realization sometimes it
takes a while though for life-changing
events to really make them mark and
Borlaug initially flunked the entrance
exam into the University of Minnesota
clearly not one to shy away from hard
work he enrolled in a junior college
it's ultimately graduated from U of M's
College of Agriculture with a degree in
forestry
[Applause]
[Music]
Paulo had initially plans on using his
degree in forestry but when the
possibility of a job with the Forest
Service disappeared he had to make other
plans
he ended up returning to school for a
degree in plant pathology and this was
happening at a dark time in America's
history and we mean that quite literally
while Borlaug was researching a
particular variety of fungal disease he
and his Co researchers stumbled upon the
discovery that outbreaks of the disease
were impacted by international harvest
cycles it was as important a moment as
his teachers lesson about fertilizers
had once been it made it clear that
everything was connected and at the time
something terrifying was forming in the
American Midwest the Dust Bowl it was an
instance of the perfect storm post-war
demand had sent the need for staple
crops skyrocketing and families hoped
for for a better life moved westward to
take advantage of the incentives offered
by the US government but that boom was
followed by the Great Depression crop
prices crumbled and those wants
optimistic families were suddenly
finding themselves unable to make ends
meet they needed more crops to sell
plowed more and more lands and when
drought came along with the 1930s that
lands no longer had native grasses to
protect it from erosion valuable top
soil was swept away in massive dust
storms called black blizzards darkening
the skies for days at a time dust and
dirt from the great plains of the
Midwest was dumped along the eastern
seaboard and even covered ships in the--
Atlantic it got everywhere it crept into
homes and into the lungs of humans and
animals alike sickening those that it
didn't kill Borlaug watched all of this
and was horrified by what he saw going
on around him but he also noticed
something area's being used for
experimentation with high yield crops
seemed to be the least impacted by Dust
Bowl conditions and he decided that this
was the path that his life was going to
take high yield crops seemed to be the
answer to two major problems these crops
would be able to feed more people but
they would also help save countless
acres of untouched wilderness
if agricultural land was made more
productive Borlaug thinking went there
would be no more need to make more of it
prairies and wetlands would remain
untouched entire ecosystems would be
preserved and native species could
continue to thrive
it was an admirable plan but in
hindsight there are many who had point
out that the road to hell is paved with
good intentions now if you're enjoying
today's video I think you'll also really
enjoy today's sponsor which is super
science focused and they can help take
the knowledge that you're learning in
this video a bit of a step further
brilliant is a problem-solving based
website and app with a hands-on approach
they've got over 60 interactive courses
in maths science and computer science
now it's the new year it's a new decade
in fact so it's a perfect time for a
resolution and whether you're a student
or a professional or someone who wants
to understand the world better
brilliance is the place for you so why
not make your resolution this year
improving that knowledge just a little
bit each day with brilliance brilliance
as always they're improving their
platform and recently they launched a
new course on algorithm fundamentals it
starts simple with basic drag-and-drop
exercises that will have you thinking
like a computer scientist in no time it
also recently added more interactive
content more of the puzzles and
challenges that brilliant the famous for
their brilliant it's a great compliment
watching educational videos like this
one and it will really help you
understand and even master complex and
technical subjects so if you'd like to
support by graphics thank you very much
and get unlimited access to all of
brilliance in-depth maths and science
courses please head over to brilliant at
or forward slash buyer graphics to get
20% off their annual premium
subscription and let's get back to it
wheat has been a staple crop for
somewhere around 10,000 years and it's
changed quite a bit with the guidance of
generations of farmers by 1944 bollock
had already spent a few years
researching bacteria sides and
fungicides but with the arrival of world
war ii priorities changed he partnered
with the Rockefeller Foundation was
transferred to the International Center
for maize and wheat improvements or CI
mmm whitey to use the Spanish acronym
this is where things start to get
surprisingly controversial within four
years
Borlaug succeeded in improving four
strains of wheat his versions were
highly resistant to stem rust that
fungal disease that had been studying
earlier in his career and they also put
out higher yields and matured about two
weeks faster than previous incarnations
of the various strains he also ended up
with strains of weed that possessed
daylight insensitivity which essentially
means they can be grown almost anywhere
in the world as suddenly it no longer
matters how many hours of daylight they
were exposed to bowl organism did it by
performing thousands upon thousands of
crossings carefully selecting wheat with
the traits that they were looking for
and crossing them to ensure not just
healthy plants but fertile ones as well
it sounds like they were creating an
early version of GMO crops and while
they sort of were but they weren't
actually altering DNA though they were
instead selecting plants based purely on
an individual stalks say strength or
yield it's worth noting though that
journals like Nature do consider him one
of the early pioneers of the movement
and his family has spoken out about the
damage done by the anti GMO sentiment
that is sometimes present in the world
the technology Borlaug and his team
worked with was nothing along the lines
of what we have today but by 1954 they
had their miracle seeds they were the
opposite of what most people might
expect envision in wide springfield's of
tall slender stalks of wheat or logs
America wheats was based around dwarf
wheat which is brilliant for a few
reasons the shorter the wheat stalk is
the less energy and fewer nutrients
goines are growing an inedible stalk
that just goes to waste the short stalks
a stouter which means they don't bend
under the weight of their kernels and
there's less competition for sunlight as
with most things that sound too good to
be true there was a catch these
high-yield dwarf seeds required more
than standard wheat as well as needing a
ton of fertilizer to reach their full
potential Borlaug campaigned heavily for
the use of organic fertilizers with his
crops but getting that much organic
fertilizer meant raising more livestock
which would consume the crops that were
being grown it was just a cycle with no
easy straightforward answer aside from
the widespread use of inorganic
fertilizers regardless of long-term
complications Borlaug's new strain of
wheat was a massive success almost
immediately by 1956 Mexico doubled their
wheat production and no longer needed to
rely on imports that only continued to
increase by 1963 their production was
six times what it had been in 1944 there
was no doubt the varieties of wheat
Borlaug had carefully cultivated had the
potential to change the world and he
became a champion for the idea of
spreading these high-yield crops into
poverty and famine stricken areas that
were in dire need of a new and reliable
food source in 1963 Borlaug took his
program to Pakistan in India where he
promptly failed to convince them to
adopt his sweet as a staple crop but
conditions there were growing more dire
by the day food shortages were
widespread and for many famine and
starvation were all too real by the time
Borlaug was able to arrange for a 35
truck convoy to take seeds to LA and
then load them on a ship bound for India
war had broken out one more obstacle for
him to overcome when they received the
first shipment and planted their thirst
fields they did so while working a
stone's throw from artillery fire and
that's had to be absolutely terrifying
delays meant the crop didn't get planted
in time but even so crop yields rose
mass starvation was averted and by the
mid-1970s both India and Pakistan was
self-sufficient when it came to wheat
production Borlaug was credited with
saving hundreds of millions of lives and
averting a major famine at the same time
his high-yield crops are spread even
further introduced to countries like
Iraq Afghanistan Iran Lebanon Egypt as
Borlaug's wheat strains started to grow
and bellies started being filled he was
awarded the Nobel Peace Prize it was
1970 and Borlaug's world had come full
circle while his roots were firmly
planted in America's heartland his
parents had hailed from Norway a country
they'd left due to extreme food
shortages
Borlaug had set out to solve that
problem
and while it seemed as though we had by
the 1980s Borlaug had expanded his
program to bring not just high yield
crops to Africa but crops science
education as well he shouldered a huge
burden removing malnutrition and poverty
from towns and villages across Africa
here he was mostly successful with the
development of a high nutrition strain
of corn called quality protein maize but
much too Borlaug's outrage he suddenly
found himself fighting an uphill battle
in the 1980s lobbyists were suddenly
attacking his largest supporters
including the Ford Foundation in the
World Bank because his high yield crops
relied heavily on inorganic fertilizers
environmental lobbyists started putting
on the pressure the green parties of
various European country started leaning
on their governments to appealing for an
ends to the export of fertilizer to
Africa for the most part the
government's listened for Borlaug it was
clearly a case of the elite deciding
what was best for the poor and the
starving he didn't mince words saying of
the lobbyists they've never experienced
the physical sensation of hunger they do
then lobbying from comfortable office
suites in Washington or Brussels if they
lived just one month amid the misery of
the developing world as I have the fifty
years they'd be crying out for tractors
and fertilizers and irrigation canals
and be outraged the fashionable elitists
back home were trying to deny them these
things
fortunately for Borlaug it wasn't a
battle he needed to fight alone by 1984
he had fallen in with two unlikely
allies the first was former American
President Jimmy Carter Carter who was
from an agricultural backgrounds had
also taken up the cause of improving the
state of the agricultural industry in
Africa the second was a little less
expected it was a really Sasakawa so the
cour was well his 1995 obituary referred
to him as the last of japan's a class
war criminals and also a monster of
egotism greed ruthless ambition
political deviousness and a love of the
limelight he's also been described as a
lovable rascal and well all of those
descriptions were in the first paragraph
of that obituary a self-educated and
larger-than-life figure who was so
thrilled to be instructed to report to
prison as a world war two a caste war
criminal that he showed up with a brass
band to announce his arrival he was
certainly colorful then his tale is one
of illicit love affairs
illegitimate children of treasure
hunting and a gambling empire ends in
1982 a collapse while attending a geisha
party then 84 years old it was another
four years before he had an apparent
change of heart where he had once Fanta
Japan's ultra nationalist People's Party
and fashioned himself in the style of
his heroes Hitler and Mussolini he now
founded the Sasakawa Peace Foundation
through his foundation he funneled an
insane amount of money into education
and various other benevolent charities
sure it was in an attempt to snag a
Nobel Prize but I mean it's the thought
that counts right it would be impossible
to imagine a figure more different than
Borlaug the quintessential Midwestern
farmer humanitarian and mastermind of
all things era cultural but somehow
proving that sometimes truth really is
stranger than fiction
they formed a partnership Sasakawa had
been reportedly shocked that Borlaug who
held the Nobel Prize he so desired for
himself had been denied funding for his
philanthropic work in Africa
so Sasakawa gave him a call Borlaug
hesitated at first and not because of
the rather shady nature of his newfound
benefactor he was 71 by this time and
Sasakawa convinced him to kick off his
projects by simply saying I'm 15 years
older than you so I guess we should have
started yesterday Sasakawa and Borlaug
with Jimmy Carter along to round out
this truly strange trio headed to Africa
they selected the locations for their
projects which included Ethiopia Nigeria
Ghana and Tanzania and it wasn't long
before the production of staple crops
like wheat corn and sorghum skyrocketed
[Music]
not everyone who studied Borlaug's work
was thrilled with the outcome while
lobbyists it stymied his work in Africa
they weren't the only ones warning of
the dangers of high yield crops son like
the ecologist Vandana Shiva condemns the
crops is contributing to a reduction in
soil fertility and genetic diversity
basta claiming the crops reliance on
fertilizers that kicked off a long term
cycle of rural poverty and debt the
farming practices he promoted were
undeniably high maintenance and critics
began to question whether or not it was
all sustainable critics also condemned
Borlaug for another reason and this well
this is gonna get dark when he
shouldered the heavy burden of
eliminating world hunger there were
those that suggested that people were
hungry for a reason and that widespread
famine was the Earth's own sort of
population control the more food there
is the thought process goes the more
mouths there will be to feed state that
some touted as problematic like I said
is going to get dark over the course of
his career Borlaug had an arguments for
all of the problems naysayers had with
his work and he was a lifelong
proponents of population control
addressing Lee as high yield crops an
elimination of hunger and hand in hand
with that when he was growing up on a
subsistence farm during the hardships of
wartime and economic depression families
tended to have handfuls of children they
were needed to work the farm after all
justice he and his siblings did and it
was sort of assumes that not all of her
family's children were going to survive
he knew that first hand to burying his
baby sister when he was just a boy it
was an Indian diplomat named Karen Singh
he made the comments developments is the
best contraceptive and the statistics
support that idea when food is plentiful
and when high yield crops are put in
place societies tend to have lower death
rates and in turn lower birth rates it
both seems counterintuitive and it makes
sense at the same time and it was
precisely these types of arguments that
Borlaug often found himself embroiled in
still in spite of the naysayers and the
critics Borlaug continued his work in
2003 he visited Uganda and noticed that
there was an outbreak of a new type of
wheat stem rust disease this was the
very disease that he had started out
surveying decades before thanks to his
vigilance the USDA and the University of
Minnesota confirms the outbreak and
started down the path of finding a way
to stop it with the help of Bill and
Melinda
and the formation of the Borlaug global
rust initiative over the course of his
career he was awarded an incredible
number of accolades in addition to the
Nobel Peace Prize there was also the
Congressional Gold Medal the
Presidential Medal of Freedom the public
welfare medal from the National Academy
of Sciences and while the list goes on
and on and includes more than 50
honorary doctoral degrees from
institutions around the world
he didn't just receive awards though he
also gave them in 1986 with the help of
general foods he established the World
Food Prize and endowment of $250,000 to
those who have gone above and beyond to
eliminate world hunger and poverty
according to his daughter he truly did
work up until the day he died and that
day was September the 12th 2009 he
passed away at his Dallas Texas home
after a battle with lymphoma his
daughter later said that he had always
considered his work unfinished and his
last words were one of concern he was
worried about the farmers in Africa who
was still struggling over the course of
his life Borlaug was credited with
saving somewhere around a billion lives
with his Green Revolution and even said
himself there are no miracles in
agricultural production although the
families he saved with his high-yield
crops might have a different opinion but
long-term things are a little less clear
when food riots broke out among the
starving in 2008 Borlaug sweet strains
covered about 18 million hectares of the
planet's surface the problem was the
same people were multiplying too fast
for the food supply those touched by the
Green Revolution in Asia were feeling
something else Farms were consolidated
into the hands of the rich but all of
these high maintenance crops was
starting to show dams were built waters
were drying up and those that were still
running contains high amounts of the
same fertilizers required for getting
those high yields his efforts in Africa
faced roadblocks that have proved all
but insurmountable a lack of
infrastructure made getting the massive
amount of fertilizers the farmlands
difficult and irrigation was another
challenge but back in 1970 when he
accepted his Nobel Prize Borlaug seemed
to know that these challenges were not
going to go away easily he said it is
true that the tide of the battle against
hunger has changed for the better but
Ebba tide could soon set in if we become
complacent civilization as it is known
today could not have evolved nor can it
survive without an adequate food supply
the first essential component of social
justice
is adequate food for all mankind so I
really hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below do not
forget to subscribe we got brand new
videos just like this about four times a
week so hit that notification bell
you'll find out about all of those also
please do check out our fantastic
sponsor brilliance they're linked to
below and thank you for watching